there are two big risks that exist in
business the first is the execution risk
the second is the idea risk now you
could maybe make an argument for a third
being you know environmental risk
regulatory risk things like that but i
would say big picture is does the idea
fundamentally work you know is dr having
strangers drive kids around in cars is
going to be a really good idea uber
right or creating lockers for cats is
that going to be a good idea i don't
know right or am i going to be able to
execute the idea itself and if you don't
know who i am my name is doctor mosey i
own acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that over a hundred million
dollars a year and i have nothing to
sell you i like talking about business
stuff and hopefully making fewer people
broke in the world makes me die happy
okay so i was having a really good
conversation with a friend of mine uh
who's a software entrepreneur he's had
three or four software companies none of
them have really hit um and he's about
the same age as me and he and i sit in
very different financial positions at
this point in our life and we were
having a really in-depth conversation
around this topic which is appropriately
measuring risk and so one of the issues
that i see with a lot of newer
entrepreneurs is that they overestimate
the payoff for a risk and underestimate
the cost number one and second is they
overestimate the likelihood of success
they're going to have and they
underestimate the risk in terms of the
likelihood that they fail and i think
this is really interesting because he
and i were discussing the first quote
that i have it's kind of it's in the
intro of my book uh by jeff basis i'll
read it to you right now outside returns
often come from betting against
conventional wisdom and conventional
wisdom is usually right given a 10
chance of 100 times payoff you should
take that bet every time but you're
still going to be wrong nine times out
of 10. we all know that if you swing for
the fences you're going to strike out a
lot but if you're also going to hit some
home runs the difference between
baseball and business however is that
baseball has a truncated outcome
distribution when you swing no matter
how well you connect with the ball the
most runs you can get is four in
business every once in a while when you
step up to the plate you can score a
thousand runs this long tail
distribution of returns that's why it's
important to be bold big winners pay for
so many experiments jeff bezos and so
the thing is is that there are two big
costs when you're making these risks one
is you've got the money and things like
that but i think the biggest cost is
time and so if you think about portfolio
theory which is uh for example like
venture capital vcs though let's say
they take 50 companies on and they're
betting the fact that one of those 50
companies is going to you know 100x and
pretty much carry the return to the
entire portfolio and for the vast
majority of the other ones they will
either go out of business or basically
not really do anything spectacular and
so for the vc for the venture capital
the investor it makes sense to take this
approach because they're going to get
very good returns uh using you know you
know using this this method whereas if
you are one of the 49 you know founders
who has pretty much all of their net
worth invest in this thing and it takes
five years of your life away to only
fail it can be harder to swallow and so
he and i have had very different careers
and lives and it's because we we value
risk differently now he would say that
he is not interested in making money and
he just wants to do something really big
and really cool i tend to be more money
focused uh or money money driven
whatever you want to say uh because i
think that the accumulation of money
will allow me to do really cool things
later on in my life and when i say later
i mean like you know give me 20 30 years
um of doing this and i think we can do
that now the reason that i want to bring
up this topic is because picking the
business that you're going to go after i
think is a very important question that
you're going to ask yourself and you
have to understand that you're probably
going to fail many times before you are
successful and one of the hardest
questions in entrepreneurship and this
is also one of the things that come up
in the conversation is when do i push or
when do i pivot right when do i keep
pushing when do i keep persevering on
this idea that's not quite working uh
and when do i pivot and it's one of the
hardest questions in entrepreneurship
because you don't know whether it's you
or the idea and that's what's hard
because sometimes it's like how many
great business ideas have the founders
have abandoned six inches from gold
where they just needed to push a little
bit harder and they were going to have
the breakthrough and i hesitate to talk
about the subjects i think most people
just don't know how to push at all and
so you know i put that as a big caveat
now when we're talking about business in
general i and this is my difference from
my friend i prefer to only go after
ideas that i think have virtually no
risk of not being ideas that people want
which then leaves only me as the
variable the execution risk that it can
be done well it can be well businessed
right and so i think in a lot of ways
this is just alex's two cents most newer
entrepreneurs i think would be better
served going after boring businesses
that have established needs right so
people want to have you know businesses
want more customers people want to make
more money people want higher paying
jobs people want to have skills that are
valuable people want you know to lose
weight people want entertainment like
these are all things that are not going
to change over time and so what that
allows you to do is hone your skills at
business because you know if it doesn't
work it's only you it's only your fault
if it doesn't work right and so because
the problem is that having the
perspective from which to make a
judgment on whether you have product
market fit can be i think a much harder
decision of when to push and when to
pivot right and as a total side note
because i think this is really
interesting i think there's three big
questions that are really dichotomies
that um you have to manage as an
entrepreneur right one is one to push in
one to pivot the second is how much do i
consume versus how much do i invest
right because you're going to be living
your whole life if you always forego the
immediate satisfaction you may reach the
end of your life and never have enjoyed
anything right so there's a little bit
of a balance there that you have to
strike right and it probably shifts over
time but there still means that there's
some level of consumption even early on
in your life and at the same time you
also don't know if you're gonna live
tomorrow right and that's where it gets
really interesting and uh it's a
personal question right and the third is
is kind of the balance between like how
much do i you know delegate uh to other
people versus how much do i do right
because you got to do something and you
can delegate everything right like and
so there's there's balances here and so
today it's just about the push and the
pivot uh and idea risk versus execution
risk and so for the newer entrepreneurs
you probably suck at business and that's
okay and that's because you're new which
is totally reasonable totally acceptable
and of course you should suck because
it's hard and a lot of people do it
right if you want to be in the top one
percent it's one percent of people that
means you have to beat 99 other people
out of 100 in order to be the top one
percent which is only 400 thousand a
year right not only it's a lot of money
right and so the thing is is that
instagram makes everyone feel like if
you're not making money or you're poor
which is not true you can save 400 000 a
year for not that long and uh and have a
lot of money you know what i mean and so
anyways back to the point if you're
picking businesses the difference that
he and i had is that his mentors always
went super super big they wanted to go
change the world and whatnot but what i
don't think we see or appropriately risk
or value is the graveyard full of people
who went big and struck out and i think
is an interesting caveat to this jeff
bezos gives this example and i want to
dive into it in a little bit more detail
let's let's zoom out for a second let's
eliminate jeff bezos elon musk warren
buffett from the names that you have in
your head if we were to think what would
be required to be number one in the
world at a thing right you'd have to
have the natural proclivity right
because if you're competing against
everybody the people who are gonna have
natural advantages based on genetic code
upbringing whatever are going to they're
gonna win more right so that'd be the
first thing we'd want if we wanted to
create this person who's gonna be likely
to win number two is they'd have to have
a tremendous amount of skill right so
they'd have the natural proclivity the
the nurture that created an environment
where they had work ethic to pursue the
skill right so they have to be very very
good and then third they'd have to be
lucky right because if you think about a
whole bunch of people like imagine
everybody who's born really you know has
natural tendencies or proclivities
towards these activities right and then
does a ton of it in terms of volume so
they get very good what then separates
them luck right the people at the very
very very top have all the all of the
things aligned comma and luck and so
it's interesting that he has this quote
around risk um because one of the things
that's unique about um bezos and even
elon right and this is probably a
further discussion on business strategy
overall is that they've had virtually
limitless access to capital right like
as in they can basically raise money
endlessly to fund these risks right and
so the equation that he said which is
imagine you go to vegas casino there's a
there's a table that has a 10 chance of
winning but you get 100 times pay out
when you do right if you can play the
game on an unlimited time horizon then
you absolutely should just play as
played as many times as humanly possible
right but most of us do not have
unlimited spins right and that's where
this gets more interesting and so if you
were to imagine a dollar as a year of
life okay that you have in your
entrepreneurial career and let's say to
build something really epic would take
10 years and that's like minimum you
know what i mean like facebook was 20 is
20 years old now right which is kind of
insane to think about i think it's 20
years old is it 20 years old i feel like
it's 20 years old it's pretty old 15
years old it's pretty old right let's
just say 15 right if you want to build
something epic which means and how long
does it take to test the idea before
moving on right that's another big
question like how how long does it take
to really give it your all on a thing
and so we were having the discussion and
he said i think we should say 35 would
be you know you have 35 years of life
and uh you know how long do we do we
chunk and we agreed on five years as a
mid ground because it takes 15 to really
you know see something all the way
through if we said 15 was the chunk that
didn't seem realistic because it doesn't
take you 15 years to find out something
doesn't work right um and so it's that
about so we said five was that was the
number you can come up with your own
right and so a more realistic way to see
this right would be uh you know you've
got a one out of 10 shot at 100 times
payout but the minimum bet is five and
you've got 35 bucks interesting right
the conversation changes now let's say
that you're now 15 years in let's say
you bet three times you lost all three
times which would be reasonable that
would be expected that you'd lose three
times you could even lose all three of
the first times but now you're 15 years
in and you have still no money huh how
do you feel about yourself right how do
you feel about your skill what's your
reputation all these things kind of
weigh in you know what i mean this is
why i think this is a really interesting
discussion and so i will give you my two
cents because he and i disagree on these
things because i have the perspective
that all the people that i know are the
wealthiest in the world eliminate risk
so that's what they do they control risk
they they virtually eliminate they
figure out ways to play the game in new
ways where they cannot lose right i'll
give you an example if the rock came out
with a i'm trying to think of something
he hasn't come out with because he came
out with apparel and whatever let's say
he came out with uh let's say he came
out with a book right let's say let's
see the rock writes a book maybe he
already has written a book i don't know
and he writes a book what's the
likelihood that it's not a bestseller
virtually zero right it's virtually zero
so he's basically limiting the risk
because he controls another variable
which has a massive audience right and
you can build that deliberately and so
when we think about these things the
richest people that i know control risk
and only play games where if they wait
they win and my friend has not taken
that approach and he's like hey i just
want to go big or go home and the thing
is is that he's gone home more than he's
gone big and so i uh i will give you
alex's two cents and you can choose to
do what you want with it and i'll just
explain my views on risk i tend to go
with the highest likelihood bet and i
tend to if i have two bets let's say one
where i have a 10x payoff for a you know
one out of two shots right which would
be a two to one risk adjusted return all
right if you're curious you just
multiply the payoff by the the by the
likelihood all right that's a 5x sorry
i've messed that up but you get the idea
you multiply the payoff by the
percentage likelihood and if i had an
equivalent risk adjuster return in
another one but i had a higher
likelihood of achieving it so if i had a
5x that i or a 6x that i thought i had a
4 out of 5 chance of getting versus a
10x that i had out of the math on it but
whatever a one out of two shot at
getting i would pick the the four out of
five shot that had a lower upside that's
me and i think part of that is because
the games that are set up that way are
usually going to be just execution risk
businesses and i feel like i can i can
pay that down in other ways right i can
pay down that risk so i can virtually
nothing's guaranteed but i can virtually
guarantee the outcome and so my goal is
to string as many of these virtually
guaranteed upsides in my favor for a
long enough period of time that i let
compounding work because compounding on
a long enough time horizon creates the
outsize return and so the idea is how
can i play how can i get as many w's in
a row and as few ls as possible for a
long enough time horizon so that i
create the outside's return comma and
get delivered pretty cool and and
stress-free you're not stress-free but
like a pretty cool life along the way
right now if we played the game the way
that we talked about earlier where you
have the 35 years that you can bet and
your three bets in you're 15 years in
and you don't have anything that can be
pretty hard hard on your ego harder
reputation maybe you learn bad habits
like there's a lot of things cause you
won't know especially if there's an idea
risk that's at hand like is it me or was
it the idea right and so for that reason
i'm in favor of the significantly lower
risk and he and i were you know talking
back and forth he's like you know what
i've observed from you is that you just
you go for the sure thing and that's a
hundred percent what i do that is i've
always gone for the sure thing and then
i just continue to try and trade up the
upside of my sure things right so the
first short thing you can have is a very
high paying you know income job and then
the next sure thing would be like if i
were to quit a job i would make sure
that i had more income from my side
hustle probably where i believed it
would be very reasonable for me to get
that you know within a very short period
of time so then i would you know make
maybe that switch and then i would look
at you know all the opportunities that
existed and think okay what are these
things uh on a risk adjusted basis and
this is again where people make it you
know errors like just assume like you
have to take the negative assumptions
and i would say like the the better i
get at this at thinking this way the
more i i continue to make which is i'm
gonna assume everything goes wrong what
then do i make right and so if you can
just say like assuming none of the good
things that you think are reasonable are
going to happen happen can you still win
and i think when you think that way what
happens is you give yourself room to be
pleasantly surprised and exceed
expectations but what happens is when
you set up the game that way where
you're like i'm assuming these are the
five things that i think will happen and
will go right but i'm assuming none of
them are gonna go right do i still win
and if you can still win then that is an
opportunity worth pursuing in my opinion
and so that's um that has been the
approach that i have taken which is how
can i virtually eliminate downside risk
how can i eliminate idea risk and how
can i and when i say virtue eliminate
downside i meant to say the execution
risk so how can i eliminate idea risk by
only going after things that people i
already know want and then how can i
stack the chips in my favor like the
rock where if i want to write a book i
want to make sure it's a bestseller no
matter what right how do i do that and
then think about all the things that can
go wrong assume they go wrong and then
think what would i do in order to still
succeed even with all these things going
wrong and then i think when you take
those actions you may not hit the 1000x
return but let's paint a different game
that you could play so let's say you
could play
there's the two games one was the one
that jeff bezos outlined right which you
got uh you know one out of ten shot at
getting 100 times payoff the game that i
prefer to play is how can i get a 3x
payoff with a 95 chance of certainty and
i still have the same 35 right minimum
bet well i'll bet 5 and get my three and
then i'll bet my 15 i'll get it now be
at 45 and then i'll bet my 45 and i'll
be at up there we go i'm already at 120
or whatever sorry got my 100 times
payoff by thinking about it from a
risk-adjusted basis now it's not going
to be sexy it's not but if you double or
triple or 5x things enough times you get
to the 100x very quickly and you can do
it with limited downside knowing that
you've controlled for the idea risk and
have only focused on the execution risk
which is yourself and so that's how i've
thought about risk with opportunity that
i thought i would share with you because
it was a really cool conversation um i
hope i hope it gave you some light in
terms of uh at least how i think of
things um and maybe some of those ideas
uh could serve you so mostly nation love
you guys i don't deserve you but i love
you for being as awesome as you are
leave questions in the comments for uh
for future vids they're really helpful
for me um and i'll see you in the next
one mostly nation you guys are the best
and if you could do me the biggest favor
in the entire world click the like
button comment below so i can answer
more of your questions in the videos and
make sure that i'm not just making stuff
out of my head but answering the
questions you guys actually want like
comment i'll see you in the next vid